Brendan how are you doing well look at
this couple I love it oh thank you
you look so open up
together in Elegance
everybody everybody get in get in here
Family Affair tonight yeah yeah this is
your first time back since 2003 correct
five but who's who's counting what does
it feel like to be back and especially
on a night like nice I mean we're we can
do this again for one thing I mean it's
never lose sight of that fact but
on top of that it's a celebration
there's some really great films that
were made during a challenging time in
world history we all lived through it
but we pulled together and we made we
did work that showed that we can care
about one another even more and it shows
up in the performances and on the screen
you know we all know that Hollywood is a
is a place but do you realize that you
actually have like a like tentacles in
every actor everywhere you know yes
we've got hongchao she was your co-star
she's nominated then Michelle yo she was
your co-star The Mummy three she's
nominated kihui Kwan was it goes down in
Encino Man he's nominated it really is a
community
it's homecoming I'll give you that it's
a nice reunion
I'm so excited to see them again and
like I said when I first saw him we're
still here man we're still here does Dad
have major cool point
s you'll give him a heart that's pretty
cool he's pretty cool I think I think
it's a bit of both I mean he's our old
man he's he's always been cool but we're
always going to rag on him at least a
little so yeah it never changes does it
always dead that joke still don't
yeah oh yeah right he'll go left
you got one I think my personal favorite
has always been when we were kids and
I'd say I don't like broccoli and he'd
say broccoli loves you
Brendan I love you
thanks guys
[Music]
foreign